[Musik]
gerichtet
ich habe schon meine hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sail israels
heute gibt es ein patentrezept und zwar
ein richtig einfaches applet das habe
ich tatsächlich online gefunden und
wandeln sie das paket baguette massiv
automatische paket das paket besteht nur
aus den zutaten wenig mehl zucker wasser
hefe und genau das ist ganz wichtig und
ich habe aus den zutaten einfach drauf
zu kommen und der teig ist wirklich
super einfach wird nur mit einem löffel
kurz zusammengerührt und das eigentliche
problem dabei ist man muss zwei stunden
warten bis der teig aufgeht das heißt
man muss es eben gut vorbereitet und
gehen lassen und ihn deshalb kann man
eben auch aus anders machen also das
sonntagsfrühstück entlang der frühe
aufstehen aber das nimmt man auch gerne
mal in kauf für selbst gemacht verrät
david und so einfach geht's starten wir
gleich und ich zeige euch mal die
zutaten fürs parkett traurig zehn gramm
hefe 300 milliliter warmes wasser eine
prise zucker 380 gramm mehl das bis 550
e mail und einen telefonservice von etwa
acht gramm
die zubereitung ist es ganz einfach ich
nehme die hefe und löst sich im wasser
auf eine prise zucker noch kurz dafür
dabei wie hefe aufgelöst ist kaum das
mehl mit sein und absetzung 550er mehr
weil dadurch das passiert ein bisschen
feiner wird aber normale 405 weizenmehl
geht natürlich auch und ihr könnt das
lincoln verwenden jetzt noch das kalb
mit rein und die zutaten einfach so
lange rühren bis das mädel mit dem
wasser verbunden ist
wetten
und leider ziemlich einfach zu
verarbeiten und auch keine
küchenmaschinen dafür jetzt weiten
abdecken da ist auch ziemlich viele
zuschauer ziemlich weit wie ihr sehen
könnt ohne abdeckung und für zwei
stunden bei zimmertemperatur lagern
damit auch schön aufgeht ganz viele
kleine bläschen bildet und der und das
paket somit später etwas locker wird
weil entweder sie da zeigt ist so aus
wir am rand ganz schön bitter
luftbläschen die später durch paket
richtig schön locker machen und ihr seht
der teig und ich werde das paket jetzt
gleich auf einem backblech packen und
zwar habe ich es umgedreht weil es hier
einfach ekelhaft oberfläche habe und ich
habe hier ein baguette backblech für
zwei blöcke dauer bakbone damit nichts
und trotzdem den backofen und ich nehme
noch eine zweite frau des black denn es
werden drei paketen falls jetzt aber
kein baguette blätter können jetzt auch
ganz normal in bagdad damit hat die form
ich gar nicht so schön aber für trotzdem
schön hier schönen kleinen löcher mit
dabei die eben diese typische form auch
ausmachen
jetzt muss ich hier meine arbeitsfläche
gut wählen
und jetzt gleich den flüssigen zeigt
aufgeschüttet mittel machten den tag
einfach nicht mehr zu akt zu bearbeiten
ich möchte einfach diese luftige
struktur beibehalten und ließen ihn
jetzt darauf dass er nach dem drauf
gleiten
da kommt man ordentliche schippe
obendrauf lief in drei zonen einteilen
[Musik]
auf meine kappe und feen hier gleich
rüber
[Musik]
nicht einfach der länge nach in die bad
bank vor
[Musik]
die baguette im vorgeheizten backofen
bei 240 grad heißluft gebacken für etwa
20 minuten und ich zeige mich jetzt mal
ganz gut hier den unterschied zwischen
heißt schon um luft und was ihr hier das
symbol für umluft das ist so ein
ventilator mit ober- und unterhitze und
da passiert folgendes im ofen die umluft
west nur die heiße luft im ofen um die
einfach durch die oberen unter nichts
zustande kommt dadurch wird das gewächs
getroffen meint luft sieht das ganz
anders aus da haben wir ein symbol kann
ich den ventilator mitteln greift außen
rum und das heißt einfach das um den
ventilator herumlaufen und der blick zum
heiße luft rein und es braucht mittels
gepäck nicht auf und geradezu magnetisch
uns wirklich perfekt also 240 kaltluft
für etwa 20 minuten und damit die kurse
schön wird kommt noch ein kopf mit
heißem wasser hinein
blütenregen
fertig ich hab noch abkühlen lassen aber
warum nicht auch ganz besonders gut und
jetzt schon also richtig schön knusprig
wird besser abschneiden
guck mal die vielen großen poren machen
das paket natürlich sehr luftig locker
[Musik]
da braucht man fünf nicht mehr viel das
so vielleicht olivenöl und gutes ein
gutes und paar oliven dazu und perfekt
ist das leckere abendbrot alter
festmachen wollen nach machen und dann
geht auch fällig - block der jeder
fehler noch mal alle zutaten für euch
und alle tipps und im prinzip war schon
wirklich einfaches rezept und ashland
vettel ich wünsche euch ganz viel spaß
beim nachmachen und wir werden gibt noch
viele risiken paket auffressen
bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]